what an exciting night it was an
overwhelming voter turnout in this
year's midterm elections gave both
parties something to celebrate the new
Congress will be divided with Democrats
leading the house and Republicans in
charge of the Senate expanding their
majority this means president Trump's
agenda will face new challenges
Democrats picked up more than two dozen
House seats to take control for the
first time in eight years but the GOP
added to its narrow majority in the
Senate after the president's last minute
campaign blitz the election was a big
day for female candidates at least 114
women won their races to serve as
governor senators and Congress women
that includes incumbents and new
candidates Nancy Cordes is here with the
key results and the significance of last
night's outcome Nancy I good to see you
again
seismic realignment that we are about to
see in Washington DC House Democrats
will now have the power to investigate
the president and his cabinet and block
funding for his top priorities like the
border wall at the same time if they or
the president want to get anything done
the next two years they will now have to
work together change came tonight it
wasn't a tsunami but the blue wave was
big enough we want a better nation
Democrats defeating moderate House
Republicans in urban and suburban
districts I don't want anyone to feel
sorry for me tonight Nancy Pelosi who
lost the speakership in 2010 when her
party lost control will now seek to
reclaim the gavel
we were drained the swamp of dark
interest money Democrats made health
care their number-one issue
and exit polls showed it was top of mind
by far for voters to helping to drive up
turnout across the country but that
turnout had a downside for several
Senate Democrats up for re-election in
Republican states keep that fire burning
Missouri's Claire McCaskill Indiana's
Joe Donnelly and North Dakota's Heidi
Heitkamp got swamped by GOP challengers
all three senators had opposed the
president's Supreme Court pick Brett
Kavanaugh
we knew we took some votes that a lot of
people would criticize
the only Senate Democrat to bat
Cavanaugh West Virginia's Joe Manchin
did survive but delivered this sharp
rebuke to the commander-in-chief mr.
president I want you to be President of
the United States not to divide it's one
of the most closely watched Senate races
was in the Lone Star State this election
was a battle of ideas Republican Ted
Cruz beat back a texas-sized challenge
from Democrat betcha
O'Rourke who wrapped up huge funding and
a following but ended up falling short
by three points in this campaign holds a
very special place in the history of
this country every day going forward and
you have made that possible Cruz offered
this olive branch to O'Rourke's
supporters I am your senator as well my
responsibility is to represent every
Texan he'll be joined in the Senate by
Republican Mitt Romney the former
presidential nominee is finally heading
to Washington as the junior senator from
Utah the victory tonight is more than a
victory of a candidate for the United
States Senate I believe it's a call for
greater dignity and respect Democrats
did manage to knock off one Republican
senator Nevada's Dean Heller who
conceded to his challenger Jackie Rosen
early this morning and we're still
waiting for a winner to be declared in
Arizona and a winner in Montana so we
don't have the final count just yet but
it looks like Republicans are going to
add about two or three seats to their
Senate majority I just underscore that
headline or maybe put the yellow
highlighter pen so Congress is not only
going to have more women it's going to
be the most diverse ever no question and
a lot of firsts in the house first
Native American women first Muslim
American women so you're gonna see a lot
of interesting new faces come January
there's something last night for
everybody something to talk about this
morning in a good way for themselves
Nancy thank you